first the talks on a new trade agreement
we had hoped to conclude a canada-style
free trade agreement
before the transition period ends on the
31st of december this year
but as things stand that will not
now happen we remain absolutely
committed to securing a candid style fta
but there does need to be a fundamental
change in approach from the eu
if the process is to get back on track
and i've come to the house at the first
available opportunity to explain why
and how we've reached this point mr
speaker we've been clear since the
summer that we saw the 15th of october
last thursday
as the target date for reaching an
agreement with the eu
the prime minister and the commission
president ursula van der lion
agreed on the 3rd of october that our
negotiating team should work intensively
to bridge the remaining gaps between us
and we made clear that we were willing
to talk every day
but i have to report to the house that
this intensification was not
forthcoming the eu was only willing to
conduct
negotiations on fewer than half the days
available and would not
engage on all of the outstanding issues
moreover the eu refused to discuss legal
texts in any
area as it has done since the summer
indeed
it's almost incredible to our
negotiators that we've reached this
point in the negotiations
without any common legal texts of any
kind
and then on october the 15th the eu
heads of state and government
gathered for the european council the
conclusions of that council reaffirmed
the eu's original
negotiating mandate they dropped a
reference to intensive talks
that had been in the draft and they
declared that all
all future moves in this negotiation had
to be made
by the uk although some attempts were
made to soften this message by some eu
leaders
the european council reaffirmed those
conclusions as authoritative
on friday this unfortunate sequence of
events has in effect ended the trade
negotiations
because it leaves no basis in which we
can actually find agreement
there's no point in negotiations
proceeding as long
as the eu sticks with this position such
talks would be meaningless and would
take us no nearer to finding a workable
solution
and mr speaker that's the situation we
now face that's why the prime minister
had to make it clear on october the 16th
that the eu had refused to negotiate
seriously for much of the last month or
so
the eu had now at the european council
explicitly ruled out a free trade
agreement with us
like the one that it has with canada and
therefore this country should get ready
for the first of january 2021 with
arrangements that are more like
australia's
based on simple principles of global
free trade
now if the eu wants to change this
situation and i definitely hope it will
it needs to make a fundamental change in
its approach and make clear it's done so
it has to be serious about talking
intensively on all issues
and trying to reach a conclusion and i
hope it will
but it also needs to accept that it's
dealing with an independent and
sovereign country now
we've tried to be clear from the start
that we would not be able to reach an
agreement inconsistent with that status
and i do not think mr speaker that if
you could accuse us
of keeping that a secret and yet the
proposals that the eu discussed with us
in recent weeks which it presents as
compromises
are simply not consistent with our new
sovereign status certainly not yet
so mr speaker well i do not doubt that
many on the eu side are well intentioned
we can't accept the negotiators
proposals require us
to provide full permanent access to our
fishing waters
with quotas substantially unchanged to
those which were imposed
by eu membership we can't operate a
state aid system which is essentially
the same as the eu's
with great discretion given to the eu to
retaliate against us
if it thought that we were deviating
from it and more broadly
we can't accept an arrangement which
means that we stay in step with laws
which have been proposed and adopted by
the eu
across areas of critical national
importance
so in a nutshell mr speaker we've been
asking for no more than what's been
offered in trade agreements to
other global trading countries such as
canada terms which of course the eu said
last year it had no difficulty offering
to us
we're not even asking for special favors
reflecting our 45 years as a member
state
during which we paid in every every day
more than we took out
quite the reverse but even if this
new arrangement is impossible for the eu
that i must inform the house
that we will be leaving on december the
31st
on australian style terms and trading on
the basis of wto rules
now with just 10 weeks left until the
end of the transition period
i have to emphasize that's not my
preferred outcome nor is it the prime
ministers
we recognize that there will be some
turbulence but we've not
come so far to falter now when we are so
close to reclaiming our sovereignty
we have to be in control of our own
borders our fishing grounds we have to
set our own laws
we have to be free to thrive as an
independent free trading nation
embracing the freedoms that flow as a
result
so it's important mr speaker that i turn
to the preparations that we're now
intensifying
for the end of the transition period and
these apply whether we have a free trade
agreement or otherwise of course
now i'm not blind or blase about the
challenges ahead
particularly given the additional
problems that we have dealing with the
covered 19 pandemic
but leaving the eu on australian terms
is an outcome for which we're
increasingly well prepared
ever since the uk decided that it would
leave the single market in the customers
union
on december the 31st government and
businesses alike have been working hard
to prepare
for the new procedures that were the
inevitable result
and i'd like to congratulate businesses
for the resourcefulness they've shown so
far
and we want to work with them so that
they continue responding as
energetically flexibly
and imaginatively as possible to the
challenges of change and we also want to
work with them to prepare for the
opportunities ahead
including those stemming from our new
free trade deals
such as the agreement with japan struck
by my right honourable friend the
secretary of state for international
trade
which of course grants us far more
favorable access to the world's
third biggest economy than we had as an
eu member
and i'd also like to put and recommend
particular thanks to the road haulage
industry
customs intermediaries and others for
their constructive engagement with
government
including at our extensive roundtable
last week
now this week the prime minister and i
will be speaking again to business
leaders
to discuss preparations for life outside
the eu
we'll continue to listen to their
concerns and we will redouble our
efforts to help them to adjust and
prosper
and of course the exo cabinet committee
which meets daily
will intensify its operational focus on
business readiness
we continue to work closely with our
partners in the devolved administrations
because we want to ensure that every
part of the uk is ready for the end
of the transition period and in these
final 10 weeks we're also intensifying
our public information campaign every
firm will find information needs
on new rules which govern trade between
britain and the eu
on gov dot uk forward slash transition
and today hmrc is writing to 200 000
traders that do business with the eu
to reinforce their understanding of the
new customs and tax rules
we're also putting in place i.t systems
to help goods flow across borders
we're giving business access to customs
professionals
to help with new ways of working and
we've also planned how to fast
track vital goods in the first few weeks
to get around eu bureaucracies
we've already published and indeed
updated our border operating model
we've announced 705 million pounds worth
of investment
in jobs infrastructure and technology at
the border
and we've also strengthened our maritime
security
to protect our fishing fleets and
safeguard our seas
and in addition mr speaker to the steps
that we're taking we're also continuing
our work with the eu in the withdrawal
agreement joint committee
and i'd like to update the house on its
latest meeting which took place earlier
this morning
coming only three weeks after the last
meeting i'm pleased to report that in
this
form the approach from the eu is very
constructive
there's a clear imperative on both sides
to find solutions and we remain
committed to working
collaboratively with the eu through the
joint committee process
at our last meeting in brussels i agreed
with my co-chair vice president
shefkovic
that we would intensify discussions to
implement the withdrawal agreement
primarily around citizens rights and the
ni protocol
our officials have since held numerous
sessions and today in london
i reiterated the uk's commitment to
upholding all our obligations under both
the withdrawal agreement
and the belfast agreement we agreed that
we'll publish a joint update on citizens
rights
and i'm pleased to confirm that almost 4
million eu citizens in the uk
have now received status under our
scheme and we also discussed our work
to implement the northern ireland
protocol we're taking steps to implement
new agri-food arrangements
and we also acknowledge the eu's
concerns about appropriate
monitoring of implementation we now have
a better understanding of their requests
and the reasoning behind them
and we've confirmed that the specialized
committee will work intensively in order
to ensure
that we can make progress in this area
and also with respect to gibraltar
and the sovereign base issues now a lot
remains to be resolved before the end of
december
but we have made substantial progress on
implementation
and i look forward to further engagement
with vice president chefkovich in the
weeks ahead
and i want to put on record my personal
appreciation for the constructive tone
and the pragmatic spirit
which with which he and his team have
approached our discussions
mr speaker in his statement on friday
the prime minister looked ahead to 2021
as a year of recovery and renewal when
this government will be focused on
tackling covert 19
and building back better we're getting
ready to do now what the british people
asked of us to forge our own path and
not to acquiesce to anyone else's
agenda and on the negotiations our door
is not closed
it remains a jar and i very much hope
the eu will fundamentally change its
position
but come what may on december the 31st
we will take
back control and so mr speaker i commend
this statement to the house welcome to
shutter minister rachel
thank you mr speaker and can i thank the
minister for advanced site of his
statement this afternoon
at the last general election the prime
minister said that he had an oven ready
deal
ready to go the withdrawal agreement was
a starter course but we're still waiting
for the main meal
a trade agreement with the european
union
at the weekend the right honourable
gentleman was reminded of some of
his previous remarks in 2016
when he assured the country the one
thing that will not change is our
ability to trade freely
with europe even at this late stage
mr speaker labour expects the government
to reach an agreement with the european
union
that honors that commitment it is a
question of competence
and it is a question of trust it is what
this government promised the british
people
of course we were supposed to have a
deal by now this is the third
deadline that the prime minister has set
himself and it's the third
deadline that the prime minister has
missed initially he said that a deal
with the eu
would be sorted by july and then he said
september
and then he said last week will the
right honorable gentleman
explain to the house why the government
finds it so hard
to meet its own deadlines and so hard to
achieve
its own promises yesterday when the
minister
toured the television studios he would
he was asked what the chances were now
of securing a deal and he said it was
less
than two-thirds can he tell businesses
and can he tell this house
the current probability given that he
has just said
that events have in effect ended the
trade negotiations
over the last three days we've heard
more posturing than solutions
more excuses than explanations
mr speaker it's time for the government
to take responsibility
now of course everyone needs to prepare
as best they can
however mr speaker it is a bit rich for
the government to lecture businesses on
getting ready
when the government can't even tell them
what they are getting ready for
so let's be clear if the talks have run
out of road
then many industries will face
prohibitive tariffs from 10 percent for
exporting cars
to at least 40 percent on exporting lamb
to britain's biggest market in just 10
weeks time i ask again mr speaker
is that what the government want
businesses to get ready for
and is it even possible for those
businesses to do business
on those terms
the minister will remember the right
honourable general will recall that i
raised the concerns of the car
manufacturing industry
on the 1st of october at cabinet office
questions and the possibility
of tariffs but also on rules of origin
the minister agreed to meet with the
automotive industry and with trade
unions
the smmt and unite followed up with a
joint letter on the same day the 1st of
october
however mr speaker i am now informed
that 18 days later
that letter has not been replied to and
that meeting has not been happened
at what point did the british government
give up on british industry
and when will the minister be meeting
with those businesses
because it's all well and good to say
prepare but if you can't even bother to
get
a table with them i ask again what are
they supposed to be preparing for and
what support is the government giving
them
now the minister in his statement today
thanked the road haulage industry for
their efforts
you'll also remember mr speaker at
cabinet office questions the
minister said that the road haulage
industry had been far from constructive
so
i welcome the uh thanks he gave them
today but earlier this month
i was with a haulage firm with my right
honourable friend the member for hull
west and hessel
in the hull it's fanta it was a
fantastic business
established over 100 years ago and yet
they don't know
how many of their fleet of lorries will
be able to operate in the eu
come the first of january how mr speaker
and how minister
are they supposed to prepare for that
now government ministers have blindly
referred to leaving with no
trade deal as trading on australian
terms this morning
the business secretary was pressed on
the difference between an australian
deal
and leaving with no deal and he admitted
that it was semantics
semantics mr speaker now they can call
it no deal
they can call it an australia deal they
can call it a narnia deal as far as i'm
concerned
but let's be honest about what that
means and let's be honest about how
damaging it is
for this country now the prime minister
promised
and someone says from a sedentary place
it's not damaging 10
tariffs on british cars being exported
to the european union
that is damage 40 tariffs on land being
exported to the european union
that is damaged and if any member wants
to stand up and tell their constituents
tell british industry and tell british
farming that that is not damaging
be my guess but it is not the truth now
the prime minister promised the uk would
prosper mightily without a trade deal
with the eu
so given that confidence will the
government publish its full economic
impact assessment
on the implications if no trade deal is
achieved broken down by industry and
broken down
by the regions and nations of our united
kingdom
it may at least help us to understand
what we're supposed to be planning for
and while the government lectures
businesses about being match fit
the government's own preparations are
badly off-pace
so let's look at those in late july the
government announced 50 million pounds
of funding for customs intermediaries
could the minister update the house with
how much of this the funds
businesses have drawn down and the
latest figures for the number of customs
agents
trained up to be ready for the 1st of
january
the government have given authorisation
for a number of lorry parks so how many
of these
inland border facilities as the minister
likes to call them has been started work
on
and how many are now completed of the
i.t systems needed
can the minister list how many have been
um how many
um are on track and whether the crucial
goods vehicle movement system
has been tested with all haulage
businesses
the minister mentions business
preparedness so let me just touch
on that what is happening in terms of
security
and what is happening in terms of data
sharing i'll just conclude
mr speaker this government must deliver
a deal which provides guarantees and
safeguards on workers rights
environmental standards
and animal welfare protect jobs and do
nothing to jeopardize the good friday
agreement this was all promised last
year
time is short so my message to
government is blunt stop posturing
start negotiating and prop deliver the
deal that you promised to the british
people
[Applause]
i'm very grateful to the honourable lady
for her questions and she
she made the point that uh uh with
respect to an oven ready deal that the
withdrawal agreement
of course was uh concluded happily and
voted on by this house of commons and so
we had a deal a deal which many on those
benches opposed but a deal which now
means
that our destiny is certain that we are
fulfilling the wishes of the british
people in the same way as 52 percent of
the population of the united kingdom and
53 percent
of the population of leeds west her
inconsistency invaded to leave
we will leave we were honoring
honoring our commitment to the british
people she also
was kind enough to refer to some of the
past statements that i made which were
quoted on the television briefly
at the weekend i have to say and this is
no reflection
on her but if she's going to talk about
past
statements she'd better clear that with
the leader of the opposition who in the
past
has simultaneously favored eu membership
then said he would accept the referendum
where we left then said that we needed a
second referendum in order to satisfy
the first then so we should have an
extension on our membership
of the european union in the transition
period and now is silent on all
of those questions
it's a statement on the government
policy not the policy of the opposition
yes i was merely pointing out mr speaker
that we had an oven ready deal
and on the labor side we had
we had an indigestible dog's breakfast
and a leader of the opposition who will
not
eat his words um the um
the honorable lady also asked about uh
the the various deadlines those
deadlines are deadlines that the uk
government has set but the eu have not
met
in any negotiation both sides have to
honor their commitments and as i pointed
out in my statement and the honourable
lady did not
uh uh of course acknowledge this
we were available to talk uh every day
in the weeks preceding the european
council
and the european union were not but
but i have to say that our firmness on
this proposition i believe is now
bearing fruit
even as we were exchanging thoughts
across the dispatch box earlier mr
speaker
it is the case that my colleague david
frost was in conversation with michelle
barnier i now believe it
is the case that michelle barney has
agreed both to the intensification of
talks and also
and also to working on legal texts i
think a reflection of the
strength and resolution that our prime
minister showed in stark contrast to the
approach upon which
the opposition have often enjoined us of
simply accepting what the eu want
at every stage she asked about
preparation i think it is absolutely
right to say that we should talk to the
automotive sector that's why as i
pointed out in my statement we have a
business roundtable
with the prime minister tomorrow with
business representative organizations
and she also of course asked about
inland sites i can confirm
that we will have insight sites uh two
at ashford seventeen and waterbrook one
at ebsc one at terms gateway one at
northwest one at birmingham one at
warrington one at hollyhead
one in south wales and another at white
cliffs in dover
all of these sites will bring extra jobs
and investment to the uk as we forge a
confident
path ahead